Ich bin heute hier, die
Enthaben der Unterschuldigung.
Bevor wir uns über ihre Aktuelle
Bechverden unterhalten,
würde ich gerne über ihre
Personnien Daten eine Frage
stellen.
Natürlich brauchen sie Daten.
Ja.
Ich würde gerne über ihre
Personnien Daten eine Frage
stellen.
Ja, klar, brauchen sie Daten.
Ja.
Ja, wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Rosvita Hagen.
Önten Sie bitte Ihre
Vorname und Nachname einmal
buchtebieren.
Ja.
Rosvita R-O-S
W-I-T-H-A
Rosvita
und der Familie namens Hagen.
H-A-G-E-N.
Frau Hagen.
Mhm.
Spreche ich richtig aus?
Ja, richtig, ja.
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie bitte?
Ich bin 62.
Wann sind Sie genug geboren?
Am 18. Mai 63.
63.
Mhm.
Und welcher Tag?
Am 18. Mai.
10.
18.
Okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 62.
Ich bin 63.
Stellt in meinem Ausweis.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Hm, ja so.
80 Kilo ungefähr.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Was führt Sie zu uns,
Frau Hagen?
Ja, also ich habe
heftigste Bauchschmerzen,
die sich überhaupt nicht verbessern.
Ich habe die Bauchschmerzen,
die ich in der Brücke habe,
die ich in der Brücke habe.
Das tut so oben im Bauch.
Das ist heftig wie.
Das strahlt,
das strahlt sogar bis in die Schulter aus.
Ganz komisch.
Das sind ganz heftige.
Welche Schulter?
Die rechten Schulter.
Ich habe mich schon dreimal übergeben.
Mir ist so wahnsinnig schlecht.
Ich habe ein schlechtes Gefühl.
Die Schmerzen sind sehr krass.
Wie lange haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Mittag schon angefangen.
Vor 2 Stunden.
Oder ungefähr 2 Stunden.
Ja, vormittag hatten wir einen kleinen Sektempfang.
Da habe ich ein bisschen
die Schmerzen,
die ich in der Brücke habe.
Da habe ich ein bisschen Krabbensalat gegessen.
Wir haben Schluck Champagner getrunken.
Es gab ein bisschen Lachsschnittchen.
Ich darf da gar nicht dran denken.
Der wird mir schon wieder schlecht.
Es sind wirklich sehr krasse Schmerzen.
Ja.
Haben Sie Kartoffelsalat gegessen?
Kartoffelsalat oder?
Nein, in einem Lachsschnittchen.
Und Krabbensalat.
So schwimmst du.
Ich habe richtig verstanden.
Vor 2 Stunden.
Hat angefangen.
Ja.
Ich habe auch eine Schmerz.
Ich habe angefangen.
Könnten Sie bitte sagen,
wie Ihre Schmerzen sind?
Könnten Sie bitte ganz genau beschreiben?
Ja, der kampf dich, der ganze Bauch zusammen.
Das zieht sich immer so zusammen.
Und es ist also
ein sehr heftiges,
ja, das ist ein sehr heftiges,
ja, drückende, stechende Schmerzen.
Puh!
Das ist ja so fast wie wehen so ein bisschen.
Das kommt immer in so Schüben.
Mir ist wahnsinnig schlecht.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen
auf einer Schmerz,
wobei null, gar keine Schmerzen sind.
Sehen Sie, dass Sie sich nicht mehr schmerzen.
Sie haben gar keine Schmerzen.
Sie sehen, dass sehr stark die Schmerzen entspricht.
Bei 18 sind die Schmerzen bestimmt.
Das ist richtig, richtig heftig.
Sie haben 3 Mal erbrochen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ich bin froh, dass alles raus ist.
Aber mir ist es trotzdem noch so schlecht.
Ich darf gar nicht an das Essen denken.
Sie haben jetzt
Überkeit?
Ja, ja, habe ich ja gesagt,
dass mir wahnsinnig schlecht ist.
Wie ist Ihre erbrochen,
wie sieht es aus?
Ja, das ist halt die Reste von den Essen.
Das ist zum Glück alles, glaube ich, draußen.
Da kann eigentlich nichts mehr sein.
Ja, ja, so ein bisschen gelblich.
Und halt das Zeug, was ich gegessen habe.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt,
die Schmerzen strahlen nach rechten Schultern aus.
Ja, ganz komisch.
In den Rücken strahlen die Schmerzen?
Nein, das strahlt hier so hoch,
nach rechts hoch in die Schulter rein.
Wo ist das?
Wo ist das Schmerzen ganz genau?
Könnten Sie bitte...
Also oberhalb vom Bauchnabel.
Rechts Seite, ja.
Nein, in der Mitte.
In der Mitte, okay.
Haben Sie Durchfall oder haben Sie Probleme mit Sturrgang
oder wass wass?
Ja, das habe ich eigentlich schon lange,
lange durchgeführt, weil ich immer wieder Durchfall habe.
Und ja,
da mache ich mir eigentlich schon längere Zeit Gedanken drüber.
Aber ich habe gedacht, das geht auch schon wieder weg,
ist ja von alleine gekommen.
Aber das habe ich tatsächlich schon längere Zeit,
dass ich immer mal wieder Durchfall habe.
Insbesondere, ja, da passe ich eigentlich auch ein bisschen auf.
Wenn ich fettiges Essen gegessen habe,
dann habe ich mich dann so schneller durchfallbekommen.
Haben Sie heutzutage nur frei oder?
Ja, jetzt minimal, ja.
Wie viel mal täglich?
Eigentlich war ich, es ist ja fast nix unten angekommen.
Ich habe das ja alles erbrochen, aber ich war...
Ein, zwei Mal war ich auf der Toilette, ja.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme mit Wassalas?
Nein, normal, habe ich da eigentlich keine Probleme, aber...
Haben Sie brinnende oder schmerzhafte Wassalas?
Schmerzhaft? Ist das nicht, nee.
Aber was mir tatsächlich aufgefallen ist,
so, als ob ich zu wenig trinke,
also, dass der Urin ganz dunkel aussieht, ganz komisch.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Beleuchungen oder...
Ja, Beleuchungen...
Beleuchungen?
Ja, im Bauch.
Normalerweise eigentlich nicht so ausbrichst du.
Volle Gefühle.
Ja, mir ist wahnsinnig schlecht, ja, das ist volle Gefühl, ja.
Aber normal habe ich das nicht.
Wie gesagt, wenn ich Fett gegessen habe,
dann habe ich schon mal Durchfall,
und dann tut mir der Bauch auch so ein bisschen weh,
aber so wie heute, das ist ja ganz was anderes.
Sind diese Schmerzen erst mal aufgetreten oder...
Also, so was habe ich noch nicht erlebt, dass das so heftig ist, ja.
Wissen Sie,
in Ihrer Gallenblase
ein Problem hat, oder?
Ja.
Ob ich fast eine Gallen habe,
eine Gallenblase, wüsste ich nicht.
Ja, okay.
Ist Ihnen andere Beschwerden aufgefallen?
Ja, das ist jetzt ja alles nur, weil ich heute Morgen...
Ich nehme an, dass es von dem Essen kommt, ja,
und von dem, vielleicht mit dem Alkohol zusammen, ich weiß es nicht.
Ja, also, als ob ich mich da vergiftet habe,
oder so, aber ich fühle mich unglaublich schlecht, ja.
Ja, okay.
Ich möchte jetzt jede aktuelle Beschwerde,
zusammenfassen.
Sie haben seit zwei Stunden Oberbau Schmerzen
und Sie haben dreimal erbrochen.
Sie haben Übelkeit.
Nach dem Essen, diese Schmerzen auch getreten.
Nach dem Essen sind die aufgetreten, ja.
Die Schmerzen sind aufgetreten.
Die Schmerzen strahlen nach Rechtschutter,
nach der rechten Schulter, oder zur rechten Schulter auf, ja.
Aus und diese Schmerzen sind drückend und steckende Schmerzen.
Ja, ja, und halt absolut krampfartig, ne?
Noten Sie etwas andere, jensefigen, oder?
Ich will Ihnen gar nichts sagen.
Am liebsten will ich mich irgendwo hinlegen
und dann wird es ganz los werden, ja.
Können Sie nach dem Gespräch aushalten, oder?
Wie lange dauert das denn noch?
Nicht viel, ja.
Ja, jetzt sitzt sich ja schon eine Weile hier, ne?
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Brustschmerzen hinter den Brustbein, oder?
Nee, im Bauch tut es weh, nicht in der Brust, ja.
Sie haben keine Brustschmerzen, ne?
Nee.
Hat sich Ihr Gewicht in Leicester geändert, oder?
Was hat sich geändert?
Ihr Gewicht.
Ein Gewicht?
Nein, leider nicht.
Ab oder zu genomen?
Nee.
Haben Sie Schlagprobleme?
Ja.
Beim Einschlafen, oder?
Eigentlich kann ich gut schlafen.
Haben Sie Schutterfrost, oder Nachtweiß?
Nee, also so beinahe wie Schuttefrost hatte ich jetzt,
als mir so schlecht war, ja.
Da habe ich zwischendurch mal kurz gefroren,
aber so richtig Fieber oder so habe ich, glaube ich, nicht.
Und sind Sie in der Letzter Zeit gereizt?
Eine Reise gemacht.
Ja, also Ausland.
Ich war mal in Bayreuth und ich war mal in Dresden,
aber sonst war ich nicht weg, nein.
Aber nach Ausland?
Nein, dieses Jahr waren wir doch nicht im Ausland.
Sind Sie im Wechseljahr, oder?
Ja, das ist schon ein Weile zurück, ja.
Das habe ich schon hinter mir.
Kontrollieren Sie beim Frauenarzt?
Ja, alle Jahre gehe ich dahin zur normalen Triebskontrolle, ja klar.
Sind Sie nicht konstantig gebt?
Ja, also vollständig, weiß ich nicht.
Also gegen Covid meinen Sie, da bin ich dreimal geimpft, ja.
Und haben Sie Allergie, irgendeine Medikamenteallergie oder irgendeine Allergie?
Also Allergie habe ich nur, so eine Kontaktallergie gegen Nickel.
Nickel Allergie.
Da muss ich aufpassen, also bei so Nickel-Legierungen, ja, Schmuck,
sowas, wie auch so, sowieso nicht.
Ja, mit so Hautschuppen und so rötlichen Hautveränderungen und das Juckt dann halt.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Unverträglichkeiten gegen irgendwelche Ernährung, oder?
Nein, also eigentlich kann ich alles essen.
Also wie gesagt, in letzter Zeit gab es manchmal so ein bisschen Probleme,
wenn ich fettig gegessen habe.
Und jetzt, heute darf ich also an das, was ich gegessen habe, wirklich nicht denken.
Das wird mir schon sehr schlecht, ja.
Ich verstehe.
Und rauchen Sie?
Nee, rauchen tu ich nicht.
Rauchen Sie früher geraucht?
Ich habe auch früher nie geraucht, nee, nee, ich habe ich nie angefangen.
Ich habe eine Menge Geld gespart, ja.
Das ist sehr schön.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, so ein bisschen.
Ich trinke schon sehr gerne mal oder mal einen guten Weißwein zum Essen,
je nachdem, was es so gibt.
Also ja, das kommt schon ein paar Mal in der Woche vor, ja.
Ja, was trinken Sie?
Ja, habe ich ja gerade gesagt, Weißwein oder Sekt, je nachdem, ja.
Zwei, dreimal pro Woche, ja, oder?
Ja, so, durchschnittlich, ja.
Für eine vollständige Krankengeschichte muss ich Sie auch nach Drogenfragen.
Das ist eine routinmäßige Frage.
Wunachmessig Sie fragen?
Ja, Drogenkonsum.
Nach Drogenkonsum?
Nee, nee, aus dem Alter bin ich raus.
Nee, nee, das mache ich nicht.
Danke.
Haben Sie irgendwelche krönliche Krankheiten?
Ich war immer ganz gesund.
Ja, das einzige, ich hatte so Myome in der Gebärmutter
und dann hat man die vor zehn Jahren entfernt
und ja, seitdem ist da Ruhe, aber sonst habe ich keine.
Ich habe nicht, dass ich irgendwas habe.
Vor zehn Jahren haben Sie,
wurden Sie Myome in Entfernung gehalten?
Nee, die ganze Gebärmutter ist rausgekommen.
Ah, Uterus, okay, ja, Gebärmutter.
Haben Sie noch andere Operationen?
Als Kind habe ich die Mandeln mal rausbekommen,
aber sonst habe ich keine Operationen gehabt.
Als Ihre Kindheit wurde man sich Mandeln operiert?
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente?
Nein, ich nehme gar nichts ein.
Nein?
Bei Bedarf?
Ja, also wenn ich mal Kopfschmerzen habe,
dann nehme ich mal Aspirin
und wenn ich Verstärkte, Wadenkremfe habe,
dann nehme ich auch mal zwischendurch Magnesium-Tabletten,
aber sonst nehme ich eigentlich gar nichts.
Wann haben Sie Aspirin eingenommen?
Wenn ich Kopfschmerzen mal habe, oder so.
Haben Sie in drei Tagen eingenommen?
In den letzten drei Tagen habe ich keine Aspirin genommen.
Ich habe auch einige Fragen über Ihre Familiengeschichte.
Hat Leben Ihre Eltern?
Meine Eltern leben beide noch, sind aber beide hoch betagt natürlich.
Hat Ihre Eltern irgendwelche chronische Krankungen oder ärbliche Krankungen?
Ja, meine Mutter hat so einen Alterszucker
und nimmt irgendwelche Tabletten,
damit geht es aber eigentlich den Umständen entsprechend ganz gut.
Und mein Vater hatte schon vor Jahren einen Schlaganfall,
von dem er sich nicht so gut erholt hat.
Der ist also Rollstuhl, sitzt im Rollstuhl und wird im Altenheim versorgt.
Aber zum Glück ist so der Sprachzentrum nicht betroffen.
Der kann sich also nach wie vor gut unterhalten,
aber in der Bewegung ist er halt ein bisschen eingeschränkt.
Er kann vor allem nicht gut laufen, aber ist eben auch schon sehr alt.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich war einzeln Kind.
Und Sie sind verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben zwei erwachsene Töchter, aber die sind natürlich schon lange auf dem Haus.
Sind Ihre Tochter gesund oder?
Ja, die sind gesund, klar.
Was haben Sie, welche Beruf haben Sie geübt?
Sind Sie jetzt Rentnerin?
Nein, noch bin ich nicht Rentnerin.
Ich leite eine kleine Galerie und organisiere das da.
Und da hatten wir eben auch heute Morgen unseren kleinen Empfang,
weil er einen Künstler neu ausgestellt hat.
Da ist es dann wohl passiert, ja.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Selten eigentlich.
Meistens ist es eigentlich eine sehr schöne Arbeit.
Weil ich mich mit schönen Dingen umgeben kann.
Mit interessanten Menschen.
Eigentlich ist das eine gute Arbeit.
Und ich bin mein eigener Chef.
Ja, selbstständig.
Ja.
Ich verstehe.
Frau Hagen, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich möchte nur wissen, was wir gegen diese Schmerzen und Übelkeiten machen können.
Erst mal möchte ich Sie ganz genau untersuchen.
Und danach möchte ich bei Ihnen eine Ultraschall durchführen.
Und ja, und auch möchte ich Blut abnehmen.
Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Nach der Ergebnisse habe ich Ihnen ganz genau Ihre Diagnose sagen können.
Dann können Sie mir meine Diagnose sagen.
Ja.
Ja, gut.
Wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Ja, jetzt warten Sie hier.
Okay, und dann?
Ja, und kommt unsere Mitarbeiter und von Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Ah, okay.
Ja, dann warte ich hier so lange.
Gut, hat jemand Fragen noch zusätzlich?
Offensichtlich nicht.
Na gut.
Herr Dr. Gunger, Sie sagen mir Bescheid, wenn Sie so weit sind.
Ja, okay.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Hey, kannst du losgehen?
Ja, ich kann.
Ja.
Hallo, Frau Oberarzt.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Gün-Gümbel.
Ich bin heute bei Ihnen als Assisterin als Tätich.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen vorstellen.
Die Patientin, ja klar, wer ist das denn?
Ja, Zeit.
Ja.
Als es handelt, ja, die Patientin heißt Roswita Hagen.
Ja, Hagen, 62-Jährige Patientin.
Sie ist 1,63 m.
Sie wiegt 80 kg.
Sie ist 1,63 m groß, ne?
Ja, und sie ist 16,5.1963 geboren.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt auf einer Schmerzskala 8 vom Seen.
Ja, die Patientin berichtet, dass sie nach dem Essen mit Alkohol und Lachschnitt
fertigen Essen diese Schmerzen bekommen haben.
Sie hat auch Vomitus und Überkeit.
Sie musste 3-mal erbrechen.
Und diese Schmerzen strahlen nach rechten Schultern.
Die strahlen in die rechte Schulter aus.
Ja, in den...
Das heißt ausstrahlen, ne?
Die Schmerzen strahlen in die rechte Schulter aus.
Die Frage nach Strahlung in den Rücken wurde von Patientin verneint.
Diese Beschwerden wurden bei der Patientin erst mal aufgetreten.
Ja, und die Patientin hat seit langem Diary besonders nach dem fertigen Essen.
Heute hat die Patientin 1-2 Mal defekation.
Die Patientin berichtet über dunkel üren.
Ja, und als Vorerkrankungen haben die Patientin keine Auffälligkeit.
Keine Vorerkrankungen.
Und die restliche Vegetative an einem Nese ist unauffällig.
Ja, sie sind im Wechsel, im Wechsel, Klimakter, im Klimakter.
Sie sind vollständig geheim.
Sie ist.
Ja, bei der Patientin wurde vor zehn Jahren Uterektomi durscht geführt.
Uterektomi sagen wir, ne?
Ja, ist direkt umgedrückt.
Und in der Kinderalter...
In der Kindheit?
Ja, im Jugendlichen Alter.
Ja, im Kindheit wurde bei der Patientin Tom Silek-Tomi durscht geführt.
Und die Patientin nimmt bei Bedarf, bei Bedarf, Assetiksalisu, Zohire, ein.
Wenn die Patientin Kopche merzen, haben.
Okay.
Ja, und nimmt auch die Patientin Magnesiumpabiletten ein.
Ja, warum nimmt sie die?
Ja, ich habe das nicht gefragt.
Ich kann beim Untersuchen fragen.
Ja, in der Familienanalyse gab die Patientin, dass der Vater der Patientin Silek-Anfall apoplex gehabt habe.
Und deswegen liegt ihr Vater im Rostel.
Sitz im Rostel, ja.
Er lebt im Altenheim.
Die Mutter der Patientin hat diabetes melektris-tübschwein.
Und die Patientin ist verheiratet, hat zwei gesünder Tochter.
Sie ist selbstständig.
Sie hat künstlerische Galerie.
Ah, eine Kunstgalerie, ja, okay.
Ja, künstler Galerie.
Ja, und die Patientin hat Nickelalergie.
Die Hautausschlag sich ausert.
Die sich im Hautausschlag ausert, ja?
Ja, und sie raut nicht.
Und sie trinkt zwei, drei Mal pro Woche in der Woche.
Wein und manchmal Sekt.
Wein oder Sekt, okay.
Gut, was ist denn jetzt Ihre Vermutung?
Ja, nach der anonystischen Angaben,
vermute ich, dass die Patientin ein Polycystitis hat.
Was könnte es alternativ sein?
Polycystitis, Polydokalitis.
Oder was noch?
Und ja, das auch Magengeşwür.
Und Urkus Ventüculi.
Haben Sie denn nachgefragt, hat jemand anderes, der da mit gegessen hat,
auch solche Symptome möglicherweise,
dass wir eine Lebensmittelvergiftung ausdießen können?
Ja, die Patientin heute Mittag, Alkohol mit Lakshinit.
Ja, das war ja meine Frage, ob der unterunter mit etwas nicht in Ordnung war.
Dass jemand anderes auch krank ist, der da mit gegessen hat.
Haben Sie danach gefragt?
Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Ich kann bei der Untersuchung fragen.
Denn das wäre ja auch noch eine denkbare Differenzialdiagnose,
dass man sagt, unter Umständen eine Lebensmittelvergiftung.
Ja, das richtig.
Gut, was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Ja, ich möchte erst mal Blut abnehmen.
Auch Vitalparameter kontrollieren.
Und auch eine KIG-Schreibung.
Ja, was lassen Sie denn im Labor untersuchen?
Ja, es ist wichtig, es ist wichtig,
Leberwerte, Nierenwerte und CRP.
CRP und Elektrolyde.
Und auch Troponin.
Wenn Sie troponin abnehmen, dann ist die Frage
Hatten Sie denn irgendwann einen Zeitpunkt verdacht, dass das Infarkt sein könnte?
Ja, bei der Frauen passiert manchmal geheimnisse, geheimnisse, myocardiumfakt, ohne Brustschmerzen.
Ach so, dass es Stimmeinfarkte gibt bei Frauen?
Ja, bei Frauen, ja.
Also untypische, untypische Symptome.
Aber hätten Sie dann nicht sofort die Teilfira-Parameter überprüfen müssen?
Ja, ja, ich habe gesagt, aber nicht im Anamnähte-Gespräch.
Okay, ja.
Ich möchte, ich würde gerne erst mal mit Teilparametern kontrollieren und KG-Schreibung.
Ah, ja, okay.
Gut.
Was machen Sie da noch, diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Ja, ich möchte Urinstatus und Urinsediment untersuchen.
Auch und ein kleines oder großes Blutbild kann man kontrollieren, oder?
Ja, okay.
Jetzt waren Sie ja gerade bei der Urinprobe und was machen Sie noch?
Sie hat ja auch...
Ja, das ist...
Das ist ein bisschen Sonografie, aber Abdomen-Sonografie...
Abdomen-Sonografie, ja.
Was erwarten Sie da?
Ja, beim Abdomen-Sonografie können wir eine Stine, oder Colissi-Stitis, oder große,
ja, Wandverdigung bei der Galerie.
Und das Verstellen.
Ja, sehr gut.
Okay.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch?
Also worauf achten Sie bei der Körperlichen Untersuchung besonders bei der Patientin?
Ja, erst mal möchte ich die Inspektion durchführen.
Das ist...
Das...
Hier kontrolliere ich zum Beispiel Verdigung oder Perellung oder irgendwelche Bemerkungen.
Und möchte ich...
Auffälligkeiten.
Ja, Auffälligkeiten.
Und möchte ich palpieren, palpieren, palpation durchführen.
Ja.
Mit welchem Fokus?
Ja, das ist rechte Oberbauch, Kalambilase.
Ja, aber worauf achten Sie bei der Palpation?
Ja, es gibt einige...
Nur für Zeichen, ja auch...
Okay.
Gut, kontrollieren.
Gut.
Und ja, wenn sich Ihre...
Also die Zeichen deuten ja schon klar in die Richtung.
Was wäre denn diagnostisch, was wäre denn therapeutisch mit der Patientin zu machen,
wenn die tatsächlich eine akute Galenblasenanziehung hat?
Ja, wenn der Patient eine Qualistik ist hat.
Möchte ich erstmal Antibiotik, Antibiotische Therapie veranlassen.
Das ist wichtig.
Und danach ein Konsul von Chirurgie erfordern.
Aber was machen Sie denn mit der Patientin noch?
Ja, so viel...
Analgesik ist wichtig.
Antibiotikum.
Was noch?
Ja, das Buscopan.
Basmulise, ne? Genau.
Basmulitik.
Ja, gut.
Wie wäre die Behandlung, wenn Sie tatsächlich Steine haben?
Ja, es hängt davon ab, wie groß und wie viele die Steine sind.
Wenn die Steine im Gallenwege sind.
Ja, dann veranlässe ich eine RSP.
Wenn die Steine im Gallenblase sind, ja, chirurgische Therapie.
Ja, wunderbar.
Dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, was für Ergebnisse rauskommen bei der Frau Hagen
und wie sie ihr weitergeht.
Und wir nehmen Sie dann jetzt stationär auf, richtig?
Ja.
Und dann gucke ich mir die Patientin nach Hause mit Ihnen zusammen noch an,
wenn Sie mit den Untersuchungen fertig sind.
Gut.
Ja, dann bis später.
Okay.
Ja, wir haben ein bisschen Verständigungsschwierigkeiten.
Haben Sie gemerkt?
Ja, ich habe sie nicht so wahnsinnig gut verstanden als Patientin.
Und wir sind so ein paar sprachliche Sachen.
Da sind sie nicht so ganz super unterwegs, sage ich mal.
Ich habe ein paar Sachen direkt korrigiert.
Einigen Sachen haben sie es aber eigentlich nicht so richtig,
wie soll ich sagen, aufgenommen.
Zum Beispiel habe ich gesagt, das heißt, die Schmerzen strahlen aus.
Ja, das Verb heißt ausstrahlen.
Es ist ein trennbares Verb.
Das heißt, ich muss also, wenn ich davon spreche,
dass die Schmerzen in die rechte Schulter ausstrahlen,
dann sage ich, nach Angabe der Patientin strahlen die Schmerzen
in die rechte Schulter aus.
So, dass auskommt, muss kommen.
Das ist genauso wie mit dem Vorstellen.
Patient stellte sich mit ausgeprägten,
kohlikartigen Schmerzen vor.
Ja, das gehört dann immer noch ans Ende von dem Satz.
Trennbare Verben muss man so ein bisschen aufpassen,
dass man da nicht die Hälfte vergesst.
Dann ist mir eine Sache aufgefallen, die sie relativ häufig machen,
dass sie das Verb nicht an die zweite Position bringen.
Die Patientin auch berichtet.
Die Patientin berichtet auch.
Dann ich nehme, ne, dann nehme ich ihnen Blut ab.
Das ist ne alte Leier, sage ich ungefähr,
bei jedem Gespräch, was wir hier zusammenführen,
bei jedem ihrer Kollegen und Kolleginnen.
Wird immer wieder gerne falsch gemacht,
ist aber einfach nicht so schön.
Dann auch irgendwie so ne sprachliche Finesse.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich sie richtig verstanden habe
oder ob ich es einfach falsch gehört habe.
Sie haben gesagt, in der Familienanamnese
ergab die Patientin.
Ne, die Familienanamnese ergab
ein Apoplex beim Vater, Diabetes 2 bei der Mutter
oder die Patientin, die Frage,
oder in der Familienanamnese
ergab die Patientin an.
Der Vater habe einen Apoplex,
aber in der Familienanamnese ergab die Patientin,
klappt nicht.
Also das ist schlicht verkehrt.
Ja, dann haben wir noch einen winzigen Zahlenfehler.
Sie ist nicht am 16.05.
sondern am 18.05.
Also bei Zahlen bitte aufpassen.
Und dann haben sie was Schönes.
Sie haben garantiert etwas anderes gemeint.
Sie haben gesagt, heutzutage hat die Patientin
irgendwie so zweimal Durchfall gehabt.
Oder zweimal war sie auf der Toilette.
So, heutzutage.
Sie meinen am heutigen Tage,
heutzutage ist so eine allgemeine Formulierung,
wenn man sagt, die Jugend von heute,
heutzutage sitzen ja alle nur am Computer.
Heutzutage kann man sich Schokolade nicht mehr leisten
und Kaffee, weil die so teuer geworden sind.
Das ist so eine generelle Aussage.
Es meint nicht heute.
Heutzutage ist, also in unserer Zeit bedeutet das so ungefähr.
Also ein bisschen vorsichtig mit dieser Formulierung.
Am heutigen Tag oder heute hat sie bereits,
oder war sie bereits zweimal auf der Toilette.
Das sind so ein bisschen besprachliche Feinheiten,
aber es trägt zur Verständigung bei,
wenn man es richtig verwendet.
Gut.
Wir sollten nochmal ein bisschen was arbeiten, würde ich sagen.
Ja, wäre gut, wir würden nochmal eine Annahmnese machen.
Und ja, machen Sie sich ein paar,
was mir positiv aufgefallen ist,
was Sie schön gemacht haben,
dass Sie versucht haben,
so ein bisschen alternative Formulierungen
bei den Fragen zu verwenden.
Nicht, also nicht immer nur haben Sie,
sondern haben Sie, oder ist Ihnen aufgefallen,
hatten Sie früher schon mal entsprechende Beschwerden
und so.
Und ja, gut, das waren so meine Hauptpunkte,
die ich mir aufgeschrieben habe.
Und ja, wie gesagt, die Verständigung,
die Präzision der Sprache
ist sicherlich auch noch so ein klein bisschen ausbaufähig.
Ich musste mehr nachfragen,
als ich das üblicherweise machen muss.
Ist Ihnen wahrscheinlich aufgefallen,
dass Sie, hey, was haben wir gesagt?
Gut, ich habe Schwierigkeit beim Sprachlernen.
Ja, natürlich.
Meine Kindheit, ja.
Ich sage Ihnen ganz ehrlich,
ich möchte auch nicht im fortgeschrittenen Alter
noch eine neue Sprache lernen.
Ich bewundere alle, die sich das antun
und die den Mut haben und die das machen.
Und ich ziehe wirklich mal einen Hut vor denjenigen,
die sich dieser Prüfung stellen.
Es ist wirklich schwer.
Ich kann ja nur nicht mehr tun,
als Ihnen von außen ein paar Tipps zu geben
und zu sagen, wo sehe ich die Schwierigkeiten?
Ja, und die Schwierigkeiten liegen ein bisschen
in der Satzstellung und die Schwierigkeiten liegen
ein bisschen auch in der richtigen Verwendung
der Artikel und der Casus.
Da machen Sie einfach so grammatikalisch noch ein paar Fehler.
Das wird vielleicht nicht unbedingt tragisch sein
für die Prüfung.
Ich weiß nicht, wie streng die Inhanova sind.
Was wichtig wäre,
dass wir an der Verständlichkeit
so ein klein bisschen noch arbeiten
und dass Sie eben auch nicht so ganz
gravierende Grammatik-Fehler machen.
Das ist so deutlich.
Gut, gut.
Vielen Dank.
Für heute Abend würde ich mich verabschieden.
Ist irgendwas bekannt,
dass am Donnerstag andere Termine sind?
Wir haben heute keinen Host.
Wissen Sie,
gibt es irgendwelche anderen Pläne
für Donnerstag oder nicht?
Ja, ich denke,
das ist ein guter Punkt.
Wir können uns um 8 Uhr treffen.
Alles klar.
Dann sehen wir uns übermorgen Abend.
Dann schauen wir, wie es weitergeht.
Ihnen erst mal für heute.
Schönen Abend.
Wir sehen uns übermorgen.
Ciao.
Tschüss.